nous sommes sur le mississippi
un fleuve mythique de 3700 km qui
traverse les états unis du nord au sud
nous débarquons à kiel dans l'état de
l'illinois qui
en arrivant des scènes de désolation les
maisons s'écroulent il n'ya plus
d'épicerie et l'hôpital est abandonné le
centre-ville de kerho et marc il est
vrai
anthony cheng lice est le seul parmi ses
huit frères et soeurs qui est resté il
est postier et joue de l'orgue dans une
des seule église encore debout dans
cette ville meurtrie par le racisme
pourtant de 1900 à 1960 qu'est l'eau et
prospère une cité vibrante de 15000
habitants à majorité blanche
mais les noirs sont exclues de la vie
économique et sociale
le premier maire afro-américain de kia
l'eau a été victime de cette ségrégation
dans sa jeunesse
et
à la fin des années 60 les noirs
minoritaire en ont assez ils boycottent
les commerces des blancs qui refuse de
les embaucher
la lutte pour les droits civiques
transforme carlo en champagne les blancs
abandonne la ville au lieu de céder aux
demandes des noirs c'est le début de la
fin aujourd'hui plus personne ne
souhaite investir ou vivre ici
la population a dégringolé à 2400
habitants en majorité noire
le chanteur s'était singles win a
consacré un album complet il a passé
cinq ans à tenter de comprendre
l'histoire de la ville l'ex maire est
convaincu lui aussi que le racisme a tué
en partie sa ville monsieur d'esprit de
la population noire vient encore
aujourd'hui dans des conditions
d'extrême pauvreté
cette femme demeure dans ce complexe
d'habitation devenu un ghetto beverly
davis reçoit de l'aide sociale elle paye
50 dollars par mois pour ce logement
infesté de rats et de coquerelles
johnson shares n'en peut plus de voir
ces logements délabrés
il siège au conseil d'administration de
ces hlm où les blancs sont majoritaires
selon lui ils négligent ces habitations
où vivent surtout des afro-américains
gambie en bsb de bras
si certains parlent ouvertement des
tensions raciales
pour d'autres le sujet demeure tabou
tous se posent ici la même question
quelle eau va-t-elle survivre ni bekar
l'avenir de kerho repose peut-être sur
ses jeunes ses enfants insouciants qui
peuvent encore rêver qu'un jour blanc et
noirs vivrons égout le long du
mississippi
et